you might remember we talked um
one maybe two months ago
about the republican national committee
telling trump
if you declare
that you're running for the presidency
before the midterms we're not going to
pay your legal fees anymore
and this raised two interesting topics
one was
wow
the rnc believes maybe correctly that
trump declaring his
candidacy now would be bad for
republicans in november and that
probably is true
and then the second revelation was the
rnc is paying trump's legal fees what's
the deal with that and the most likely
conclusion that most of you came to
based on the people that emailed me is
the rnc is incentivized to pay trump's
legal fees so that he maybe keeps
himself out of some trouble that could
be even more damaging to our candidates
our being the republican party in
november but it's all very speculative
and very very uh sort of nebulous
we now have learned that the rnc is not
paying trump's legal fees for what's
going on at mar-a-lago
uh and we have a number of different
articles about this
and one of them uh politico is really
the main um news outlet reporting this
in an article called trump adds former
florida solicitor general to legal team
working mar-a-lago probe a few
paragraphs in you see trump will have to
pay on his own a person familiar with
the matter confirmed that the rnc is not
paying for trump's legal fees related to
the fbi's investigation and retrieval of
documents at mar-a-lago that's a
departure of sorts from the past the rnc
has for example paid trump's legal bills
involving new york attorney general tish
james's investigation the committee
would stop paying trump's legal fees
should he formally declare his candidacy
a step he has hinted at but has yet to
take so this actually has a number of
different potential implications number
one
trump has been
extra flipping out in public and a
little bit later in the show we're going
to look at trump did a 60 post
sort of apoplectic tirade on truth
central yesterday 60 posts including q
on conspiracy theories part of trump
being extra unhinged may be
that they're no longer paying his legal
fees
and
the second element of this is this might
explain why donald trump is having so
much trouble finding good lawyers
um they probably know the lawyers
that without the backing of the rnc for
the legal bills they're probably never
going to get paid and i you know every
time i've
dealt with a lawyer they go send me a
five grand retainer up front and i'll
start billing out of that five grand i'm
guessing with trump they're having
trouble uh getting the getting the
upfront retainer money but this could
explain why trump is having trouble
finding lawyers as well
um and it could be a very very crazy
eight weeks between now and the midterms
and there is an indictment watch i mean
it's kind of a weird term because
we're likely to learn about it after the
fact but there is now a open discussion
about
more like when will the indictment
happen rather than if
although i suggest we still wait before
we assume that that will take place so
trump now
paying or not really i guess we could
say
responsible for his own legal fees but
whether he will pay them is a different
issue we will have all of these images
and pictures and videos
including the one of the secret
documents in trump's house on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show also by the way if you want
to see some wacky wacky hate mail i got
uh follow me on instagram at
david.pacman